[Music]
what's up guys today we are making curry
puffs and it is a family favorite of
mine and what a curry puff is is a puff
pastry with a curried beef filling in
the middle so it's crispy on the outside
and soft and moist in the middle it's a
wonderful snack to have to bring to a
party a potluck and I remember making
these with my mom when I was a kid for
me it's a very nostalgic thing to make
and this is a very Cantonese kind of dim
sum and it's one of the many things that
my mom taught me over the years and it's
really sweet as my mom actually taught
this to TIFF - so Tiffany knows how to
make this as well so a little back story
on this curry puff it is a traditionally
denison like pastry and yet had a lot of
Cantonese bakeries a lot of Hong Kong
bakeries now within the culinary history
of Hong Kong Hong Kong has had a lot of
influence from other cuisines in the
world Hong Kong has been influenced by
British food Portuguese food Indian food
and because of the Portuguese food
Portugal was influenced a lot by Africa
because of a lot of the trading that
they were used to do back in the day
plus all the colonizing in Hong Kong and
Macau this region in China has had a lot
of European influences and so over the
years the curry puff has now become
pretty standard fare in Hong Kong
cuisine and I'm gonna share that with
you today to begin we are going to start
with the skillet and we're gonna pour
about two to three tablespoons of oil
first we're gonna add in our diced onion
and we're gonna saute that until it get
starts to turn translucent from there
we're gonna add our minced garlic Dante
that for a couple of minutes and let it
release its aroma and sense and once we
have the onion translucent worked in
with the garlic we throw in our one
pound of ground beef and make sure to
work your ground beef in move it around
so it does
stick to the skillet anyone have brown
all the beef and then once the beef is
browned and we have the onions and
garlic all mixed in together from there
we're gonna pour in all the spices that
we have so that's the two tablespoons of
curry powder two teaspoons of turmeric
powder the one teaspoon of cumin powder
the quarter teaspoon of sugar and
quarter teaspoon of black pepper and the
1 and 1/2 teaspoon of salt and once you
start mixing that together you'll start
to notice the turmeric powder and the
curry powder really bringing out this
beautiful yellow color into the curry
making the filling is super super simple
it's just sauteing all these ingredients
together but there are second half of
the cooking process is to bake the
pastries now in the baking process it's
very easy to dry out the filling so in
order to counter that we're gonna add in
cornstarch slurry with some beef broth
and with this we're gonna add to our
sauteed beef now once the corn starch
hits the heat if the cornstarch will
start to thicken and once you get to
your desired viscosity remove it from
the heat and we're gonna put it into a
bowl so moving on to the pastry part so
today we're going to be using a packaged
puff pastry and if you want to make a
home puff pastry more power to you
because that's actually way more awesome
than getting the packaged stuff but it
does take time to fold the butter into
the flour over and over and over again
to create that puff pastry texture and
I'm opting to do something more simple
and hopefully you guys will appreciate
the simplicity of this so we've already
accomplished all the hard parts which is
just making the filling now it's the fun
part of folding and wrapping the filling
with the puff pastries so we're gonna
take out the puff pastry from the box
since it's folded in thirds and you'll
see the creases right on those creases
we're going to cut it and then from
there we're gonna cut it the other way
around
horizontally so that should give us nine
squares of puff pastry sheets and each
square is going to be its own puff
pastry from there we're going to add one
spoonful a tablespoon of filling on top
of each puff pastry square and once
that's done
the puff pastry square and we're gonna
fold it in half diagonally creating like
a triangle shape and from there what the
trick is is you want to close off the
very top corner and the sides and kind
of work your way towards the middle of
the of each side of the triangle and you
just want to pinch it close to help you
with that having a little bit of water
on hand to close off the edges of the
puff pastry helps a lot to have on hand
some cornstarch or flour as well to re
powder your hand so it doesn't stick
your hands as much either
and so once it's folded up into
triangles we're gonna take our trusty
fork and we're going to take that tips
of the fork and we're gonna press into
the corners of the pastry and what this
does is one creates a really cool
pattern on the outside of the pastry so
it looks extra fancy do it also kind of
I guess seals the edges a little bit
more so that when it bakes it that the
puff pastry does expand it starts the
puff and when it does that it may open
up the pastry you don't want that you
want to keep it as close as possible so
it stays all the moisture stays inside
and you have this beautiful bite of
moist curried beef in the middle right
before it goes into the oven we are
gonna make an egg wash so we're gonna
take 1 egg and 1 tablespoon of water and
an egg wash is something that you're
gonna we're gonna brush on top of the
pastries to give it a nice little glassy
look
and while I we have a batch of nine puff
pastry is ready to go into the oven and
the other should be heated to 400
degrees Fahrenheit and we're gonna place
that into the oven and cook that for 15
minutes into 15 minutes we're gonna have
some awesome curry puff magic going on
in our mouths now make sure you let it
cool off for about 10 minutes after it's
done baking because the middle is gonna
be piping high we don't want to burn
yourselves or burn your tongues thanks
for our awesome afternoon snack
sometimes I even have breakfast goes
really well with a cup of tea or a cup
of matcha also I always end up having an
extra amount of beef curry I always end
up saving that for leftovers for that on
top of rice put it on toast sometimes
and you have these nice little curry
toes open-faced sandwiches it's awesome
it's multi-purpose you do whatever you
want with it and or statement and make
more pastries but like always feel free
to leave a comment down below on what I
should cook next and if you do end up
making this curry puff pastry be sure to
tag me on my instagram when you do make
it I like to check out your creations
and we can compare how perfect our
triangles are when we make these puff
pastries until next time peace
[Music]